this is the Jocko underground podcast
number 45. with Echo Charles sitting
across the table from me and just to
give a little bit of
just some perspective that we were
talking about to
everyone
um right now the date is the 18th of
March
and looking at the war as it unfolds in
Ukraine and one of the things that I
just wanted to bring a sort of very
ground level tactical view too is
well the way I think there's some things
are going to have a big impact on that
on that war
um
one of them is snipers
and the reason I bring this up is
because
snipers which in task unit Bruiser we
use very effectively against the enemy
in Iraq
the the psychological impact of snipers
cannot be overstated it is a massive
psychological impact
we certainly got reports
from the enemy you know we would
intercept reports or we'd get gather
human intelligence that would say
that the
the enemy the insurgents in ramadi were
horrified
of snipers
and what makes it so horrifying is that
you it's kind I guess it's it's almost
the uh uh there's an equivalency between
a sniper and a roadside bomb in that
you're just minding your own business
you're doing you know you're doing
you're being you're doing your bad guy
stuff
if you're out there doing your bad guy
stuff and you think you're going to get
away with you and your bad guy stuff and
you're not scared of anyone because you
kind of operate without without any fear
because you don't even see you don't see
any any American forces around you're
just out there being a bad guy
maybe you're with your buddy and you're
out there doing bad guy stuff you're
digging a hole in the road or you're
maneuvering to a fighting position or
whatever and all of a sudden your
friend's head just disappears
and you don't know how it happened you
don't know where you didn't hear a boom
right so you don't hear The Gunshot you
may or may not yeah yeah depending on
how far you are or maybe you hear it a
second later or two seconds later
and and then you look to respond and you
don't see anything you know what you see
is you see windows
so imagine you're walking down the
street imagine you're walking down the
street in San Diego
in downtown San Diego you've been to
downtown San Diego you worked at the the
bar right that's true so imagine you're
standing out in front of your bar in San
Diego you're being your bouncer
right sure and and imagine how many how
many windows and doorways can you see
yeah thousands yeah
it might be thousands right it's more
than it's probably like maybe 10 given
yeah like ten thousand because the
angles it may not be
it's not infinite but there is a really
hard a very large number because because
it's not just the building across the
street or the next building down or the
next it's like six buildings down more
than that it's every building you can
see every building you can see yeah and
the rooftop and the windows so we now
imagine
that the previous day when you were
doing your bouncing job
you were standing out there with your
friend Fred and all of a sudden Fred's
head just disappeared yeah
and now it's now it's the next day and
you're going to work how do you feel
yeah
yeah you're not going to feel good about
that no no so
we would hear those reports
when we were in ramadi of of fear
psychological fear also
there were some what we called enemy
Sharpshooters so we didn't call them
snipers because they weren't they
weren't like full on fully capable
snipers but there were some damn good
shots and they
they they made some shots and we would
hear about
those in the whole area of operations
like for instance here's one report that
started coming down was that there was a
an enemy sharp shooter that was shooting
and aiming for the groin that's what he
was aiming for
and and so this was like you know just
to give that psychological fear there
was these weird stories about
uh like chesh and snipers so now you're
thinking oh it's this is the person
that's been trained for this kind of
thing
so
I think that well the the ukrainians
have very good actual snipers and it is
taking a toll on the Russians
and here's the thing from a you know I
started I started off by saying like hey
I want to bring this down to a tactical
perspective but now I want to think
think about this from a strategic
perspective
if you've got
a hundred snipers
you got 100 snipers
and each one of your snipers is killing
three
a day three enemy a day
now you've got a a friendly force or
whatever whatever force is losing
300 people a day
just from sniper shots that they can't
react to they don't know how to defend
against
so 300 people a day
that turns into a real problem for any
military
so as I've been watching this thing
unfold in Ukraine I think it's gonna
I think that's going to leave a mark and
then on top of that we have these
anti-tank weapons they have these
anti-tank weapons
the anti-tank weapons
this is another psychological thing
because it has a tanker a young tanker
what are you thinking you when you get
into a tank you think you're getting
into a uh you know a a place that no one
can touch you no one can bother you
you're good to go now I never had this
feeling when I was in the back of Tanks
when I was in the back of well really I
was in the back of Bradley's but getting
into a Bradley
you did I definitely didn't feel like oh
I'm untouchable because Bradley's were
getting blown up and destroyed and it
was vicious to die inside of a Bradley
so I never felt any level of comfort
when I was getting into a Bradley
Fighting Vehicle to Transit somewhere in
ramadi why is that well it's because I
had seen Bradley's get blown up and seen
the damage that it caused and seen
people get killed in those
so let's say you're a young Russian
tanker
and you know you've trained and you
literally go out and you drive over
vehicles and it's cool and you can't
hear anything in there because it's such
a big giant metal awesome machine and
you're thinking hey the ukrainians don't
even have you know they've got limited
tanks so workers kind of kind of
dominate
so now the first day goes by and all of
a sudden you hear rumors right
hey wait they have some kind of
anti-tank weapons they're shooting or
tanks and it's destroying our tanks to
killing the guys inside and they well
how many how many tanks got knocked out
and all of a sudden it's like seven
twelve fourteen tanks
and now all of a sudden instead of you
feeling indestructible you feel
absolutely vulnerable and
between just those two things
Just Between the snipers
and the anti-tank weapons that are being
used both of those are being used very
effectively I think that Russia did not
anticipate this type of warfare
I don't think they're ready for this
type of warfare I don't think it's
psychologically easy to ha for them to
take
and I think
it is going to
I think I think the Russia's in for a
rude awakening I think the morale of the
troops is very very low right now of
course some of that's propaganda
I get it I but
even just seeing what's happening
I know the morale is low I know it's low
you can't take that many casualties
and not have your morale start to dip
especially because
you're not seeing even where this is
coming from you're getting sniped
and that tells you that we're exposed
guess what else it tells you it tells
you that you're fighting a highly
trained enemy
then that's a scary scary thing it's a
scary scary thing you know when you're
uh like you're in a bar yeah and
somebody you know bumps into you or
whatever
and you like hey what's your problem and
they go into like a legitimate fight
stance
you know what I'm saying sure yeah like
instantly you know oh this dude trains
so it went from hey I'm Echo and I'm
kind of tough and I'm gonna Jack this
dude up too oh man and then imagine what
you know so he goes into like a
legitimate fight stance hands up you
know he's kind of looking light on his
feet and you're like oh I wasn't
anticipating this and then
you like take a swing at him
and he just like slips your and cracks
you
and cracks you again and so you're a
little bit stunned and you realize you
just messed with someone that's a
well-trained that's the psychological
especially when you fought like the guy
looked kind of dumpy and you kind of
like you kind of Jack so you're like hey
this isn't going to be that much of a
match for me
you know what I'm saying hey if you were
if you were going to into if someone was
like Hey Echo this guy's a fighter you
need to go fight him and so you are
going in with that attitude you'd be
like okay I'm ready for it that was
Russia wasn't Russia wasn't like Hey
we're going again against train Fighters
we're gonna go and kick their ass we're
big we're strong
so psychologically it's much more
difficult so even as a TR as a coach
I don't tell you I don't say hey man
you're going to run through this guy I
don't say that because if it doesn't
happen we're gonna have problems well
guess what the Russians have been
thinking for the last five years we're
gonna run through these ukrainians
that's what's about to happen
and now when it doesn't happen
you got a psychological situation to
deal with and it is hard to deal with
and and this is unfortunate I think
there's gonna be a lot of brutality I
think there's going to be some
that is a little excerpt of what we are
doing on the the Jocko underground
podcast so if you want to continue to
listen
go to Jocko underground.com And
subscribe and we're doing this to
mitigate our Reliance on external
platforms so we are not subject to their
control and we're doing it so we can
give you more control more interaction
more direct connections better
Communications with us
strengthen this Legion of Troopers that
are in the game with us so thank you
it's Jocko underground.com it costs
eight dollars and 18 cents a month and
if you can't afford to support us we can
still support you just email assistance
Jocko underground.com and we'll get you
taken care of until then we will see you
immobilized
Underground